if I had a fighter a young fighter
trying to get in the UFC I'll put him on
Dana White's Contender series I think
that's put out the best prospects ever
besides Ultimate Fighter back in the day
that Contender series honestly is no
joke you're getting matched up those are
tough those fights man listen guys don't
sleep on data while you're looking for a
fight what's the matter with you oh
as far as finding Talent come on man
where'd you think you found Jared Gordon
the back alley beating someone up no man
you're on that right Matt listen to be
transparent I've I've never seen it you
don't have to like Dana to watch to
enjoy that show Brendan I'm not bringing
up nothing
I'm friendly with you my friend so I'm
not bringing up no there's no
there's no we had I think Dana
White Contender series is the best fight
product the UFC's put out that's true
but like you said you have not seen Dana
White looking yeah